und wir schalten zu unserem Bild
Reporter till Biermann in Basel am
Bahnhof was kannst du dort beobachten
wir berichten von
flüchtlingszusträumen wie ist die Lage
aktuell bei dir vor Ort
ja wir stehen jetzt hier gerade am Gleis
8 hier ist gerade ein Zug aus Zürich
eingefahren mit solchen Zügen kommen in
den letzten Monaten vermehrt Migranten
und Flüchtlinge nach Basel denn genau
von hier ist es nur noch ein
Katzensprung nach Deutschland und
Frankreich und das sind die Länder in
die diese Menschen letztendlich wollen
und das Besondere ist halt
dass sie ohne Probleme durch die Schweiz
reisen können das Staatssekretariat für
Migration hier sagt sie hätten gar keine
Handhabe diese Menschen festzuhalten man
müsste sie weiterreisen lassen was uns
auch hier aufgefallen ist in Basel wenn
ein Zug von hier nach Paris fahren soll
kommen französische Grenzschützer und
holen Menschen die aussehen als ob sie
vielleicht aus das Afghanistan kommen
aus Algerien kommen aus den Zügen wieder
raus und zu verhindern dass sie nach
Frankreich reisen also es ist eine
angespannte Situation hier
vielen herzlichen Dank für deine
Einschätzungen eine vom Bahnhof in Basel
und wir verschaffen uns jetzt einen
Überblick wie die Schweiz vorgeht in
dieser flüchtlingskrise wie dort
Flüchtlinge weiter geschleust werden
nach Frankreich aber vor allem auch nach
Deutschland
Bahnhof Basel Schweiz Dienstagmorgen
hunderte Flüchtlinge kommen hier täglich
an Versuchen rechtzeitig den nächsten
Zug zu erwischen wohin
auch diese drei Männer trifft Bild am
Bahnhof in Basel auch für diese Männer
ist das nur ein Zwischenstopp sie wollen
weiter nach Deutschland vor einem Jahr
fliehen die Männer vor den Taliban aus
Afghanistan ihre Flucht führt sie durch
den Iran über die Türkei von dort weiter
auf die Balkanroute
an der österreichischen schweizerischen
Grenzstadt Buchs wird die Reise
plötzlich ganz leicht nachdem die
Personalien aufgenommen worden sind muss
nur noch ein Ticket gekauft werden und
weiter geht's die Schweizer Beamten
helfen gerne den Zug nach Deutschland zu
finden denn die SBB stellt extrawaggons
für Flüchtlinge zur Verfügung fährt
diese von Buchs quer durch die Schweiz
bis in die Grenzstadt Basel von dort
sind es nur wenige Kilometer über den
Rhein nach Deutschland uns haben wir
Migranten und Flüchtlinge berichtet dass
die Schweizer Grenzbeamten gerade zu
freundlich zu ihnen sind vor allem wenn
sie ihn zu verstehen geben dass sie gar
nicht in der Schweiz bleiben wollen
sondern nach Deutschland oder nach
Frankreich weiterreisen wollen dass die
Schweiz damit eine Politik des
durchwinkens betreibt davon wollen die
Behörden nichts wissen ein Schaffner
berichtet Bild wir kontrollieren nicht
die Pässe wir kontrollieren die
Fahrausweise wenn jemand einen gültigen
Fahrausweis hat dann müssen wir ihn
transportieren so steht es im Schweizer
Gesetz jedes Land des Flüchtlinge
einfach durchwinkend verhält sich extrem
und solidarischer und so können wir in
Europa nicht miteinander umgehen das
Ergebnis 10.000 Flüchtlinge reisen seit
Monaten und kontrolliert auf diesem Weg
in die Bundesrepublik ein denn hier
wartet kein Zug zur Weiterreise auf sie
sondern ein vermeintlich besseres Leben
[Musik]